many times the Turkish government has
threatened to open its borders and
release refugees into Europe in large
numbers once again this was the scene on
the shores of the Greek island of Lesbos
already a nightmarish place for the tens
of thousands of men women and children
who crossed over from Turkey and are now
trapped here in itself a dinghy arriving
isn't any different from what happens on
any other day but the implication was
that the Turkish authorities didn't try
to stop it the Greek government is
asking for increased European support
[Applause]
Europe needs to help not just with money
but personnel and equipment it needs to
help protect maritime borders that a
Greek and European I have asked from
text to reinforce the Coast Guard with
personnel boats and technical means
Greece already operates about 40 coastal
patrol vessels and boats along its
thousand kilometer long maritime border
with Turkey and it's adding 19 new boats
over the next couple of years but it's
going to need help now if turkey makes
good on its threat to send refugees into
Europe on mass the route was being
cleared for Refugees much further north
on the land border with Turkey there
were reports of people being bussed from
Istanbul to the border town of Adina a
haven for people traffickers and unlike
in recent months the Turkish military
did absolutely nothing to stop people
then making their way on foot towards
the wide Everest River the border with
Greece
we're coming from Istanbul our aim is to
get to Germany there are Syrians with us
Algerians Palestinians there are people
from every country this want to be
honest I see now that you've arrived
here at the Turkish Greece border Greek
police are on the other side and they're
not letting migrants in we've got lots
of problems here we want turkey in
Europe to open the borders because of
these problems the immediate response
from the Greek side was to tear gas the
several hundred people who had gathered
right on the border with the Prime
Minister warning loudly that Greece was
closed to this new wave Athens also sent
more special forces to the land border
to try to prevent people coming across
the general supposition is that Turkey
is threatening to manipulate
the refugee flows as a direct threat to
the European Union to re-engage in the
situation in Syria and the humanitarian
crisis that has engulfed people in Eid
Lib if the EU turns a blind eye Greece
could end up as a buffer zone for asylum
seekers john psaropoulos al Jazeera
lesbos